[Music]
february 1st
and uh it's the first day of black
history month
it's black history month
yes
indeed
so if you're watching me right now it
means you've completely missed the point
i'm the whitest man ever
you and i are probably the whitest two
people on television are we none no not
me
i'm sorry
you got that latin blood yeah oh yes i'm
very bluesy and soulful yeah sure
mitt romney the big winner at the
florida primary i don't know how you
feel about that
okay don't know what
well our country's screwed either way
because you just don't care do you
whatevs
yeah there's a little brouhaha brewing i
love saying that mitt romney is
complaining that newt gingrich never
called to congratulate him last night
for winning the primary
yeah however romney said he did get a
call from some guy asking for a mr
haywood jablomi
the voice sounded very familiar
anyone knows heywood
the mitt romney campaign i see people in
the crowd explaining it to people next
to them
oh
hey we have some californians here i
believe yes
well guess what
i got some news for you it's being
reported that california needs to raise
three billion dollars by march
now
this according to california state
treasurer nicholas cage
yeah
it's true
he just took over for mr haywood jablomi
i'm going to keep that going night after
night
i couldn't believe this i saw this story
this month's college magazine ranked the
top 10 colleges for the harry potter
sport quidditch
yeah
actually you can find the top 10
quidditch schools by taking the top 10
party school issue and turning it upside
down
cause those nerds don't party
it's the theory behind that one right
there i see i've alienated some potter
fans in the crowd
they're the ones wearing wizard hats
and crying
hey a lot of people are kind of excited
because the government may be legally
required to release a video of the osama
bin laden killing
yeah
yeah don't get too excited for some
reason it co-stars catherine heigl
so it may not
may not do well at the box office
she will not be coming by this show
anytime soon
is what are you laughing at
nothing
just the thought of her coming by here
uh
it's funny to me
israeli scientists discovered a method
for
such a weird story i can't just start
how about this
big story out of israel
[Laughter]
israeli scientists discovered a method
for breeding tomatoes that are red on
the inside but black on the outside yeah
yeah afterwards afterwards the
government of israel said well that
wraps up the very last of our problems
what i'm saying is
shouldn't they be focused on other
things
they got a lot to deal with
yeah but if you're a tomato scientist
you got to work on tomatoes
are you here to help me or kick me in
the ass
you're right boss
thanks chum
hey the latest rumor in hollywood is
that snooki is pregnant
yeah
yeah the biological father has been
narrowed down to anyone with a
just tell penis
[Applause]